so there's no guru princess this year's
price is for engineering proteins can
you tell us what harp toppings yes I
like that question proteins are
molecules what are large molecules that
you find everywhere in your body they
conduct almost all the processes that go
on the memory the thinking the
coagulation the muscles they are really
the workhorses in our bodies if they are
so plenty because in the body some of
the proteins we have or other organizers
have are enzymes that speed up chemical
reactions but there are reactions we
want to do in chemical synthesis or to
produce fuels that those enzymes can't
do so we have to improve them this about
enzymes produced by Francis Arnold this
year for the price and that is to make
the enzymes conduct new chemical
reactions or better the reactions they
do today and the other half is about
improving binding protein so these are
protists that's attached to something
and conduct Spira logical processes by
this means for example antibodies and
this technique can then be used to
produce human antibodies against
pathogens or other substances and to
come back to the main methodist in both
prices so to say use you were talking
about evolution and when we think about
natural evolution you think it's often
described there's a combination of
chance and necessity is this what they
do yes this is I would say a combination
of chance and necessity but also quite a
big element of thinking because what
they have done is to really speed up the
evolution this nature has had billions
of years but now you want the process to
be possible in maybe a few weeks or a
year or something in the laboratory so
it was like random experiments and then
picking up the right parts of it yes I
would say in nature is what a random
process because the mutations happen by
chance maybe due to UV radiation or
something whereas in the laboratory it
was a combination of knowledge based so
you have to you have to have some idea
of which positions to bury but then you
add a random less on top of that so the
biggest difference would be that you
know what goal you have while in nature
actually the risk may be no I would say
nature has no goal but what works works
and everything that makes things better
or that you can populate a new dish is
then kept whereas in the directed
evolution the scientist defines the goal
I want to break this bone or make this
bond and I want to make it as quickly as
possible at 58 degrees or whatever is
the condition yes the scientists define
the condition
and one of the Prize laureates Francis
Arnold she knew she wanted enzymes what
why couldn't she designed them from the
beginning it's very good question and
and scientists also try to do that and
in principle we know which kind of
intermolecular forces operate in
proteins but I think the problem is that
it's a multi cognate oriole problems
it's still not possible with the
knowledge-based message today to design
an enzyme for scratch one can design
enzymes that have some catalytic
efficiency but to really really get
somewhere you have to bring in the power
of evolution to optimize them can you
tell us something about who is Francis
Arnold I think she is a very good and
very talented scientist a very curious
scientist and also goal-oriented she
knows what she wants to do and then she
sets out to do it also the other Prize
laureates George Smith he designed the
method with this phage display
hard to understand what it is but it's a
method to produce antibodies yes so the
way he designed a method he took those
phages that are these protein capsids
that have the DNA inside that codes for
making the capsid and what he did he put
in the gene for the protein he wanted to
study and he then sort of fooled the
phage to put it on its surface so this
is what we call phase display on the top
on the bottom depending on how you turn
them around but at the tip of the phage
yes and I think the key element of his
technology that really made it fly was
this physical linkage between the chain
and the protein product so that you
could fish out phages and then take out
the DNA and work further with new
generations of variations and the
Gregory winter used it to produce
antibodies but what is special about
antibodies
the special thing with antibodies I mean
it's a part of our the immune defense
these are protease that made you have
designed to have a possibility to become
very specific so the phase technology
harness is that's power antibodies have
six different loops in each binding
pocket that it can bury and this is
ideal in fact to put on a page and the
random at the terminus is to search for
very high affinity antibodies so they
can have very high affinity and high
specificity for a certain molecule and
not not react the others and then they
can be used to make drugs they can use
drugs because they can either bind to
objects or surfaces we have in the body
or they can find the things that would
try to invade us how many drugs have
been produced from this metal I
shouldn't know but I know that of the 15
most sold drugs on earth eleven are made
by this method are they very expensive
I'm sure they are very expensive but the
advantage with the face display is that
you can do white antibodies with such
high affinity much higher than you get
real immunization that you can lower the
doses you can use much lower doses you
can even use them cutaneous on the skin
you don't have reject them so there are
many advantages with no
so what do you think is next was what is
the vision for the future the vision for
the future I think we were just at the
start I think we will see many more
enzymes that catalyze bonds that we had
no clue that the enzyme could actually
do one of the latest examples from our
news lab or insights that catalyze the
formation of carbon silicon bonds and
these are bonds you don't find in nature
and there is no natural enzyme but she
managed to take one and evolve it to
form these kinds of bonds that are
important for making materials for
example thank you very much you know
clean set for being here